For the grace of God offers salvation
to all people teaching us
to live Godly life.
Jesus gave himself for us to redeem us
and to purify for himself a
people that are his very own.
We praise the Lamb who takes away our sin. Amen.
I was beautiful. Thank you worship team. Good
morning everyone. My name is Ryan Whitaker and
it's a joy a real joy to serve as one of
your elders and it is so good to see everyone
of you here. If you're new with us today. Come say
hello. We love to meet you. Also in
front of you. There are QR codes. Please reach
out to us. We'd love to say hello to you.
So let's do something fun here.
Let's go back in time together and it's August.
It's 1996 Andre.
Agassi had just
won gold at the Atlanta Olympics.
And Bill Clinton is in the White House Ross Perot.
Bob Dole. They're in the race for that people are
barely surfing the world wide web
on AOL and dial-up.
And LeAnn Rimes. She just released
her first album.
And Grunge music is still in.
in many of the women in here
were rocking the Rachel haircut
and maybe maybe you still are.
No judgment here and many
of us guys. We had a lot more here back then
too. It was the good old days, right?
August 1996 is also when we as
a church decided to change to
eldership as our pastoral Leadership
Model.
As we saw in clear guidance of scripture now,
some never gets old is following
scripture.
And you're always in the good old days when you do.
Now here's a question for you. Why would we change horses Midstream
as Dr. Rice says
from a model where a senior pastor is
the leader over everything?
To one where Elders a group of
Elders leads the church.
Well stay tuned today because today's passage
is pivotal toward that decision and
we'll see that as we go now if you
will turn in your Bibles with me to Titus Chapter
1.
And if your Bible is like a progress bar then
Titus is at about the 95% Mark
and it's right before Philemon and
Hebrews.
But while you're turning there last week John introduced us well to
the book Titus. This is a letter written by
the Apostle Paul to his coworker to
his disciple Titus who
is increte and Crete is an extensive
Island in center of the Mediterranean and
there are a string of
church plants there.
And that is the context now as we
as a church continue to read through Titus.
Let's not lose the Wonder of what we read in
here.
Because Titus 2:14 says that we Believers are
a purified people for
his own possession.
That's right. We are nothing less than his
very own.
praise God
In fact, that's the name of this new series his very
own.
And that we are his very own should change everything about
how we live everything.
And we'll see that here.
It certainly changed everything for Titus.
He devoted his life to gospel Ministry,
especially on the
island of Crete.
And we'll see why that was such a sacrifice for
him next week.
Now Paul had set the stage for these
young churches.
And Paul is now giving his first instructions
his top priority instructions to
Young Titus.
He set the stage and he left Titus as
the casting director of sorts.
to appoint elders
So let's read now Titus 1 verses 5 through
9.
This is why I left you in Crete so that you might
put what remained into order.
And appoint Elders in every town as I
directed you if anyone is above reproach.
The husband of one wife his children are believers
and not open to the charge of debauchery
or insubordination.
For an overseer as God's Steward must
be above reproach.
He must not be arrogant or quick-tempered or
a drunkard or violent or greedy for gain but
hospitable.
a lover of good self-controlled upright
holy and disciplined
He must hold firm to the trustworthy word
as taught so that he may be able to give instruction and
sound Doctrine and also to rebuke those
who contradict it.
And that is the word of the Lord for us
today.
Now before we dig into that.
We need God's help. Let's pray.
Father our hearts cry is to
be known.
and to be shepherded
So we need you lead us feed us care for
us protect us.
I ask that you help me over the next few minutes and we
ask that you draw people to yourself even.
today
come in power. Help me to speak only what's in your holy word
in Christ's name. We pray. Amen.
We can see that today's passage is about church
elders.
Paul tells Tinus from the get-go to put Elders or
leaders into place.
And to make sure that these men are living lives
that reflect the awesome reality
that we are Jesus very own.
and so
as we read through we'll let this passage surface a
bunch of questions for us. And the way these questions will look it's
kind of like a frequently asked questions of sorts or
even a catechism.
We'll start with these seven questions about Elders that
you've always wanted to ask.
Though maybe this will open up 7,000
other questions for you.
And that's fantastic. We would love to
hear your questions talk to us after the service snag
us in the hallways email us Elders at
hhbc.com.
Or come to one of our meetings.
This last year. We had a whole group of high
school boys visit us at council meeting.
And it was so good. It was such a blessing for
us to hear these boys pray.
in full Trust of God's goodness
And it was a comforting thing to me to see that the next
generation of God's church is in good hands.
Amen.
After you hear this sermon is about Elders the very first question you might
ask is.
How does this even matter from?
How does this even matter for me?
Because I'm not an elder or I don't know anybody who is an
elder or I'm hurting in some
way. I've lost something or someone.
or if your student
you may feel alone.
But hang with me, I think that you'll see in today's passage
that Christ cares for
his church the the bride of
Christ so much.
Through the institution institution of eldership.
Which does for any number
of things but also is there to precisely care for
you exactly when?
The waves are crashing against you.
And we'll see that.
To put it to put it simply Christ cares so much
for his church that he demands
Godly Elders be put in place.
for his glory and for your good
I'll say it again Christ cares for his church so much
that he demands Godly Elders put
in place for his glory and for your
good.
That's our main point. We'll see it as we go today.
Let's dig into these verses. Let's start by looking at verse
5 together.
Paul reminds Titus what his purpose is
This is why I left you in Crete so that you may
put what remained into order.
You know, it's good to be reminded because we all forget so
easily.
It's been said the only thing faster than the
speed of thought is the speed of
forgetting.
And that quote of course was said by.
none other than
the one and only
I forget who said that really so but that is
that is why?
We need to be reminded of our purpose here our mission
here.
It's our purpose. Imagine for a moment. Paul is
standing up here on stage and to
borrow from the style that he uses for verse 5.
He says to us. This is why
you are at Henderson Hills.
so that you might
equip one another to love Jesus and to
live sent.
for Titus
Paul is saying this is why I left you in
Crete.
So that you might put what remained into order and a
point elders.
And this Greek word for putting into order?
Has that has the root ortho in
it.
And that's where we get the word Orthopedics.
To set your bones straight to put your bones into order.
It's also where we get the word orthodontist. So to
set your teeth straight.
To set your teeth into order.
One day when I was a teenager.
I went to the orthodontist with my mom. I
guess I needed braces.
And I'm sitting there in reclined in that pleather exam
chair.
And the orthodontist he says to me.
Ryan
I discovered.
one of your teeth
Is smack dab?
Buried center of the roof of
your mouth.
And as a side note, we learned this year that
I've passed the same phenomenon onto one
of my sons.
And he he jokingly calls it his roof
tooth.
That's right his roof tooth with an F.
So for me, they attached a wire
to my roof tooth.
And they slowly over the course of several weeks.
They slowly dragged it into place.
And they literally put my teeth
into order.
No longer was there to be a one tooth
Island.
Now in the text today Paul has left Titus in Crete.
To not put bones or teeth into order
but to put nothing less than the
church.
into order
So as we see in verse 5 in putting the church in
order, what is priority number one?
For churches what is priority number one for
churches?
That's right. You see it in the verse priority number one is to appoint
Elders or to put Elders in place.
Elders are the wire that pulls the church
together.
Paul has just given Titus the apostolic authority to
appoint Elders God in
his compassion for you. And for the
church has tasked Elders with responsibility for
the church.
Lest the church be like sheep without
a shepherd.
Because sheep can't survive without a shepherd.
now maybe
this kind of language rubs you
the wrong way.
And I get it.
Let's push a Biblical reset button
here.
Today you'll hear a lot of Shepherd and sheep language.
Let's be clear though sheep aren't dumb.
Sheep aren't dumb.
But they are beautifully dependent.
Well, we'd say is desperately dependent
The metaphor of sheep and Shepherd is one
of care and it isn't so much
about the Sheep as it is shining the spotlight on
the leading the feeding the caring and the protecting
by the Good Shepherd himself Jesus.
It's about him.
And so it's vitally a point important that we churches have
leaders.
And Elders as well. See today are the god-given
Pastoral leadership of the church.
and make no mistake Elders our sheep to
We are sheep too, and I'm speaking as an elder here,
but we need the shepherding care of Jesus as much
as you do.
Also, if you look at the specific situation that Paul is speaking
into here.
They need to the need to appoint elders and create
is huge.
Because they are swimming in false teaching.
And maybe a better word for it is that they're drowning in false teaching?
And before you say, oh, that's Crete.
No.
We are swimming in false teaching. We're drowning
in false teaching. Do you
see that in today's culture?
And one of the elders Chief responsibilities is
to protect our church from that.
Protection is one of the ways that Christ cares for
his church.
through elders
Before we get too far, let's define some words together. So
we're speaking the same language. Let's do that by asking the
question. What are the other titles used
to describe Elders? What are the other titles used to
describe elders?
In scripture, we see the titles of Elder
pastor.
Shepherd and overseer
and all of these titles refer to the same
person.
They are interchangeable.
Yet each word offers insight into the different facets
or roles of the Elder just like
we refer to Jesus as Christ or
Good Shepherd or lamb like
we just sang.
And each of those describes a different facet of
who he is.
in a similar way
each of these titles describes a different
aspect of Elders
the main title that we see is elder.
Elder
so let's define that behind the Greek word that we
translate as Elder is presbyterus.
President that's all say presbyterus together.
presbyteras
we need a little bit a little bit more Greek Gusto here, but that's okay.
President Ross has used 70 times in the
New Testament.
And the term Elder has this connotation of those who are
usually older with wisdom and experience
and it carries with it respect and
admiration.
And you can hear some of that also in the Hebrew word for
Elder zocane.
And I hope you're not hoping for something.
A little bit more profound than this but the Hebrew word for
Elder literally means beard.
Let's continue with definitions a second word. We hear is
pastor pastor.
Now we've heard that Elder appears 70
times in the New Testament.
How many times does the word Pastor appear?
In the translation we used here the word
Pastor appears.
nowhere
It's nowhere.
But in Ephesians 4:11, that's the one passage in
Scripture that sometimes is translated to use the
English word Pastor where it says
and he gave the apostles the prophets the
evangelists the Shepherds.
or pastors
To equip the Saints for the work of Ministry for building up
the body of Christ.
Shepherds has the same exact Greek word
as pastor.
or poemain poemain
Shepherds in this metaphor of
shepherdine shepherds lead sheep to
Green Pastures and to Still Waters to feed
and Shepherds oversee the flock to
make just make decisions that are in the best decision best interest
of the Sheep.
We also see that Shepherds protect.
from wolves
The fourth word we see is overseer overseer. The
Greek word for this is episcopus and we see
this just a handful of times in the New Testament and the
title over to your highlights the management the supervision
responsibilities of the elders.
So we see many times in the Bible and we'll see it in today's text
even that the titles of Elder Shepherd
pastor and overseer are
interchangeable.
Because they all refer to the same person in today's
context see that and Elder is
a pastor.
An elder is a pastor.
Now that leads us to the question what do elders do?
What do elders do?
Now that we've defined the different titles for Elder we
can put these titles side by side.
on a string like like beads on a string
to understand what Elders do in short Elders lead
feet care for
and protect the church. You'll hear that a lot
today.
So, how do we Elders at Henderson Hills Shepherd the church? What
does it look like here for us?
While we do meet every couple weeks.
It's not in some dark secret.
With our vests on eating cookies, and we're making
arms length decisions.
That we do love cookies.
We do love cookies, but there's a lot more to it than those
meetings.
First from a high level we oversee major
Ministries.
and major staff decisions major initiatives
and we preach.
And we teach and we study God's word.
And we protect against doctrinal error and we defend.
We mentor and we disciple.
And we are mentored and we are discipled.
We get the joy and the thrill of
having people come in for prayer for healing like
we see in James 5.
Please come sometime and do this.
Grab one of us. We'd love to pray for you
expectantly that God can heal
you.
He can do it.
And he does it.
We'd love to do that.
We weep with those who weep and we Rejoice with
those who rejoice.
And we try our best to help restore broken
relationships.
Are we perfect at any of that?
No.
But by God's grace refined us even more
to Shepherd like Jesus.
And that is what Elders do.
This leads us to the next question.
Is the office of Elder the only one mentioned in the Bible is
the office of Elder the only one mentioned in the bible know
that the Bible mentions two offices.
In the Bible for leadership and service and it's
elders and deacons.
The word Deacon means helper or servant.
And it comes from two Greek words that literally means through the Dust.
or to kick up dust
and we see that deacons care for the Practical needs of the
church to allow Elders more time for prayer
and for teaching and for
leading.
In other words as David Platt says Elders are
the servant leaders of the church and deacons
are the leading Servants of
the church.
Here Henderson Hills, we praise God for the the over
80 deacons who serve in this way, especially
in their care for widows, but in so
many other Ministries.
And speaking of deacons today in fact is the
last day.
For making Deacon candidate recommendations. So if you know a man
who kicks up dust to serve
God in his people, please let us know out in
the information love in the in the lobby the information desk
there. We'd love to hear about these men.
So if we look back at today's passage where Titus is to appoint Elders,
why is Elders plural? Why
is the word word Elders plural?
The answer is that God has designed the church
to be led by a plurality.
or a group of Elders
and you can see another example of this with Paul
and Barnabas as
they're planting churches in Acts, 14:21 through
23.
When they had preached the gospel to that City and had
made many disciples. They returned to
lystra antiochonium and to Antioch and
when they had appointed elders.
plural
for them in every Church
with prayer and fasting and committed them to the Lord in whom they have believed.
So what does plurality look like at Henderson Hills?
Well on page one of our Elder manual.
There's one sentence in the middle of an otherwise
blank page and it says
we are a council of pastors of
which the lead teaching Pastor is
an equal mutually submitting to
one another in all areas of ministry.
What does that mean?
It means that John is an elder and he
is an equal alongside the rest of us.
Now plurality makes things slower.
Sometimes agonizingly slower.
Can I get an amen?
But see that plurality is a divinely given
slowing mechanism that helps
us drive toward biblical decisions. No
matter the cost.
So what are the benefits of plurality plurality protects the
church against false teaching?
And from one person driving the church into the ground there is
no one man Island.
Plurality holds Elders accountable so
important and it refines ideas and decisions
through different giftings different perspectives.
We're not all the same.
And it looks a lot like we see in Acts 15.
Plurality makes it possible to care for more people.
And it helps share the load to guard against burnout.
many of us grew up in a
church with one Pastor over everything and maybe
even a beacon board underneath
and we're not saying that single Pastor
LED churches are heretical.
But it is a significant departure from
the model that is clearly laid out in Scripture.
How does that happen?
That happens through man-made tradition.
Because this idea of One Pastor leading a church
is not found in the Bible.
It's clear. The church is Led fed cared for and protected
by Elders plural?
Back to the text still in verse 5 Titus is
to appoint Elders in every town or every Church.
And this these Church plants and create were young.
Have you ever thought that every church was a
plant at some point?
Even Henderson Hills was 1964 was when
we were launched out of our friends at First Baptist.
And we were launched under the name Henderson Hills
Baptist Mission.
It was August 1996 32 years after
we were planted.
That the light was shined on God's word for
us toward elders.
And toward breaking with tradition.
Okay, that's verse 5. Let's keep moving by asking our next
question. What are the qualifications for Elder? What are
the qualifications for Elder?
Verse 6 Paul begins laying out a set
of important qualifications that describe the necessary character
of an elder we can understand why
qualifications and are important when we read in
Acts 20:28.
Now Paul In this passage is talking to he's addressing
a group of Ephesian elders.
when he says
pay careful attention to yourselves and to all the flock.
or church
In which the Holy Spirit has made you overseers again,
that's elders.
To care for the Church of God, which he obtained with
his own blood.
Church our adversary the devil is prowling
around like a roaring lion and
he is seeking someone to devour.
And he would love to take out elders.
Because you don't have to read too far into the news to
see how often.
pastors Elders leaders fall
Through Scandal through abuse.
through Pride
If we were if we are to take God's word, seriously, we
must recognize the need to
install Godly elders.
And to remove those who are not.
Souls are at stake.
Christ demands Godly Elders Christ
demand Godly elders
and this list we're about to read is what
qualifies an elder as Godly.
Let's start making our way through starting in verse 6 together.
It says if anyone is above reproach this idea of
being above reproach can be seen as a summary over all the qualifications.
This means that he should be free from any kind
of damaging accusations.
He must have a good reputation with people outside.
The church Elders should
not give the church a bad name.
Or Christ a bad name.
Next we read the husband of one wife the statement literally
means one woman, man.
And this doesn't mean that an elder has to be
married.
Paul was single after all.
But rather if he is married.
He must be faithful to.
Absolutely committed to his wife.
including with his eyes
never before have there been so many temptations that
can destroy marriage.
husbands
love your wives.
As Christ loved the church and gave himself up
for her.
Ephesians 5:25 says
now does this qualification of husband and one wife mean that
the office of Elder is reserved for
men does it mean that it's reserved for men?
As always the Bible is our guide here.
We believe the answer is yes scripture says the office of Elder is by
men who are called by the Holy Spirit.
And this is supported by Jesus selection of 12 men
to be his disciples and then
later by the apostles establishing a policy.
That the office of Elder be only for men and
this passage is an example of that men
are seen as the primary teachers and
leaders of the congregation.
Now this doesn't mean
that women are somehow lesser.
Than men or that they don't do
vital Ministry in the church.
but rather what this is saying is that
some rules are not interchangeable.
It also doesn't mean women can't be wonderful teachers and leaders
and we'll read that from Titus in
the coming weeks.
Instead we celebrate all the ways that women
can use their gifts and serve the
church in complementary partnership with
men.
This year as we dive deeper into the topic of
women in mystery. We will see the same
in the same way all the ways that God has blessed you
to serve his kingdom. So be
looking forward to that.
Continuing still in verse 6 and his children are
believers and not open to the charge of debauchery
or insubordination.
Now his children are believers.
That's a tricky one.
Because who saves?
Not the parents.
God does he chooses?
So the Greek word underneath Believers is pestos which
means faithful as in his
children our faithful to him. There's a loyalty there. There's
a holding fast to this man.
In this idea of debauch. You just means that his
kids aren't sunken into themselves.
Just wallowing in self-indulgence.
And that they not be insubordinate just means that they submit to
his authority.
so
the Elder leads a well-managed household and
if you ask kids there will behaved.
He loves his kids and questionably. He leads
them spiritual he pours into them how he
is with his kids is visibly admirable.
Now why is this assessment of the home vital?
Because the home is the training ground for
an elder.
The home is the training ground for The Elder and Paul
says so in first Timothy 3:5 where he
says this about Elders for if someone does not know how to
manage his own household. How will he
care for God's Church?
Notice that the qualification is the home.
Not if you've knocked it out of the park in your career.
And what a reversal this is from the way the world Works, isn't
it?
in verse 7 Paul continues
for an overseer as God's Steward must be
above reproach.
Paul writes at the overseer again Elder is God's Steward
of the church.
The church does not belong to the elders.
It is God's and the elders are given the
privilege and the responsibility to lead it to Steward
it.
Continuing the Elder shouldn't be arrogant or a quick tempered instead
Elders are to be humble men.
Quick to listen slow to speak slow to anger.
Nor should the Elder be a drunkard. This
doesn't mean a Prohibition of alcohol. It just
speaks to the abuse of it.
Nor should the Elder be violent to be violent is the opposite of
Jesus that we see in Matthew 11 where he
is gentle and lowly in heart.
This doesn't mean weak.
These men are to be humble and gentle
and strong.
humble gentle and strong
continuing the Elder shouldn't be greedy for
gain.
He's not in this for gain. His lifestyle is
not extravagant and he is a generous man.
And he should be hospitable. He loves
people his home is open so much
that the hinges are worn thin on
his doors.
And he's a lover of good. He's self-controlled which
means that he can keep his desires and check. He knows
his limits.
He knows that he needs to be accountable to
other people.
And he is upright which just means just this means
that he cares about Justice being done to people.
And most importantly he is Holy. He is
Holy.
Or devout he is devoted to
Christ. He is a life. He's
living a life that is devoted to prayer and to meditation
on God's word.
And he's disciplined. The last requirement is so important. He
must hold firm to the trustworthy word as taught
so that he may be able to give instruction in sound
Doctrine and also to rebuke those who contradict
it.
This is a man. Who is White Knuckle holding
on to God's word like a life
raft?
And he is skilled in preaching and
teaching and exhortation.
And he knows biblical Doctrine.
And he has eagle eyes toward error and he
is going to confront that head on.
Those are the qualifications for Elder.
These are Godly men. They lead their family.
Well.
And they can teach the Bible.
That was the last of the seven questions. Now, we move on
to the bonus round. We have two bonus
questions that don't immediately pop out of the passage.
The first is this how many Elders should be in place in a
church. How many Elders should be in place in a church?
The answer varies of course depending on the church, but here
at Henderson Hills. We have eight active elders.
We don't set limits.
Other than there has to be a plurality
and never a single Elder.
The number is in some ways a function of the size of
the church.
But ultimately, it's God's call on a man that makes
him an elder the holy spirit makes him
an elder
So any kind of man-made quota or limit?
Is a recipe for missing God's decision his
will for the church and for the
man.
That leads us perfectly to our next question. How do you become an elder?
How do you become an elder?
First Timothy 3:1 says the sane is trustworthy if
anyone aspires to the office of overseer. He
desires a noble task.
You aspire to it and you desire it.
It may also involve someone encouraging you toward this
to maybe awaken or to affirm this
desire that you have.
For me it was over lunch at Cafe
icon. Just down the road here.
With an elder and I'll always remember this if
seven years ago, he slid a book on
eldership across the table right past the
soy sauce.
and he asked
if I might consider this
the Bible also teaches that you shouldn't Elder under compulsion, but
willingly first Peter says
But most importantly Above All Else, we've already heard
this is that you are called by the Holy Spirit to this
acts 28 2028 is clear
on this that the Holy Spirit has made you and
overseer.
What is the elder candidate candidate process look like
at Henderson Hills? Well first
we look at all 21 scriptural qualifications. We
see that in Titus one
for Timothy 3 first Peter 5.
And as we looked at we looked at that list of qualifications today,
did you notice that all of those
qualifications are observable?
And that means that they can be evaluated and
tested.
And so we evaluate and we test.
We we have a process. It's up to two years long sometimes
longer.
And in that we do training, we do classes examination
interviews mentorship as
we seek to verify and affirm your calling.
After that, there's unanimous vote by Elders to put you forward in
front of the congregation who ultimately decides and
votes if you are to be an elder of
the church.
You must attest even called by God to this
office.
and much of your qualification
is up to this idea of how are you
eldering before you Elder?
How are you leading feeding caring for and protecting the
body?
Now the reality is this it's not a popularity
contest.
Eldership is certainly an Avenue toward being less popular.
That's for sure.
Nor is it something to pad your resume? It's nothing less
than shepherding.
God's Church
We'll let that be the last question for today, but I really do.
I hope this this opens up 7,000 other questions for
you grab us. Well, we'd love to answer any questions
you have.
Now do you see how this might be an uncomfortable thing
for me in some ways to go over this list
of qualifications? Because first of all, it
shouldn't be seen at all. The elders are somehow super Christians.
or in a different League of Christianity altogether
Nor should it be seen that this list is just for elders.
It's for all of us. It's what the Christian Life should aim toward.
But here's the plot twist.
This list is impossible to meet
perfectly.
Now does that mean that this list needs to be toned down
or watered down in some way to
make it more achievable?
No, God is perfectly righteous. And
this is his standard.
But let this impossibility point us even
more to his grace.
Remember, this is more about him than us.
In second Corinthians 12:9 Paul quotes
Jesus. My grace is sufficient for you
for my power is made perfect in weakness.
Therefore I Paul will boast all
the more gladly of my weakness so that the power
of Christ May rest upon me.
Did you catch that?
Our weakness it sets the stage for the
power of Christ to rest upon us and
for his glory to be on full display
for a world that needs him.
Unbeliever the power of Christ the power
of his work on the cross for us is able to
bring you into his fold.
into his shepherding care
no matter what you've done. His grace is sufficient for you.
No matter what your life looks like no matter how your life
looks like the complete opposite of that list.
God is asking you today to trust in Jesus
his death means forgiveness for
every one of your sins every single
one of them if you turn away
from your sins and you trust in Jesus as
Lord of your life.
and the reward
Heaven it's eternity in heaven with him.
If this is speaking to you come for talk to one of us down front after
the service. We'd love to talk with you about that.
Church his power is perfectly on
display in our imperfection.
And we know this to be true.
That one day he will make perfect. Perfect.
We look forward to that now. What is our answer?
What is our answer to
this call for? Holy living and
for Godly leadership. Yes, we
do. We answer back with a changed life.
That's in submission to write Authority
Hebrews 13:17. And in
response to this awesome reality that we are
his very own.
And ultimately Christ is our answer.
His grace is sufficient.
Christ cares so much for his church that he
demands Godly Elders be put in place
for his glory and for your good.